in a twist no one saw coming on saturday
april 3rd
marvel studios dropped another trailer
for black widow if everything had gone
according to plan the scarlett
johansson-led flick would have premiered
almost a year ago but so far this is
what we've got
between the handful of trailers that
have come before mixed with teasers and
featurettes
it seems like there wasn't any part of
the movie we hadn't seen yet but
saturday's drop offered some fun new
footage and a better look at the movie's
villain
black widow is trending on twitter
instantly and fans are getting revved up
yet again for the phase four
film there was plenty to be excited
about as the new trailer mixes the old
with the new and features fresh
narration from our heroine herself
the trailer also confirms that black
widow is scheduled to land in theaters
and on disney plus on friday july 9th
with some new footage to dissect and
make sense of in the new black widow
trailer there are a handful of details
you may have missed
let's break them down since we couldn't
be given too much new footage the
trailer included a few throwbacks to
some of natasha's greatest hits
there were shots of her from the
avengers captain america civil war
avengers age of ultron and avengers end
game
most importantly we were reminded of
natasha's tragic end in endgame as we
watched her dangle from the vormir cliff
just before she went splat
these throwback clips come at the
beginning of the trailer but are tied
into a very cool instrumental moment
that comes at the end
for all of the black widow trailers
we've been enjoying our newest edgy mcu
score from composer lorne bauf this time
around the trailer ends with a black
widow avengers remix of sorts as the
themes of both movies are combined into
one epic score
and featuring what sounds like a russian
choir this is an excellent way to pay
homage to natasha who as far as we know
is no longer around in the main mcu
timeline
through black widow it's clear that
we're going to find out about natasha's
childhood and the trajectory her life
took at a young age
this new trailer shows a young
blue-haired natasha who has a
conversation with her foster father of
sorts alexi shostakov
in the comics natasha has little to no
history as a child
and there are very few details as to
what happened to her at that time of her
life
that will change with black widow which
by all accounts is going to provide some
much needed backstory for the character
we know from the mcu films that natasha
was brought into the red room when she
was a child but it's undetermined
just how young she was if she began her
black widow training at the age she
appears to be in this new black widow
trailer we're estimating it's somewhere
around
10 years old which is an absolutely
frightening prospect
we can also see a little bit of elena
bulova with a young natasha
elena likely went to the red room at an
even younger age and we hopefully will
get to see more of her backstory as well
in this new black widow trailer we get a
close-up of the character who might be
the true villain of black widow
drakov the first teaser trailer for the
film included a dracoff appearance as
well but it was only from behind and
lasted just a split second
now we get to see him up close and
personal and giving orders to taskmaster
a man who uses his ability to replicate
observed action to copy superheroes
skills
and moves to become a criminal yet
sometimes government-sanctioned trainer
while taskmaster controls the red room
it looks like draykov might be the one
controlling him
changing what we know about the primary
antagonist of black widow in his brief
appearance in the new trailer dracov
gives taskmaster orders
to bring her home likely referring to
natasha this suggests that taskmaster's
goal isn't to take out the avenger but
rather to bring her back to her shady
route
in the avengers loki even refers to
natasha as drakov's daughter and this is
the first time we've seen the baddies
face
hopefully we will get to see some sort
of background story of natasha and this
manipulative father of hers when black
widow arrives in theaters and on disney
plus on july 9th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one